aurel
bonjour je m'appelle sur maya donne
nasri je vous parle depuis l'avis de
tous seuls dans l'état de l'arizona aux
états unis d'amérique et je suis
chercheur laboratory de 13,8 search et
j'utilise le climat du passé pour
comprendre pour mettre en perspective
mais changement climatique et faire des
projections pour le futur pour l'équipe
n'a pas changé et affecter les
populations
on dit que les changements climatiques
vont faire sentir leurs effets dans
plusieurs années 10 ou 20 ans mais dans
le sud des états unis on les ressent
déjà ses effets certains phénomènes
extrêmes climatiques comme la sécheresse
ont été accentué par le changement
climatique
on ressent déjà tf1 on vient de publier
une étude au fait qui a essayé de de
reconstituer la couverture des jeux dans
les montagnes de la sierra nevada en
californie
elle nous avons découvert que sur les
500 dernières années couverture neigeuse
en 2015 à être le plus bas niveau jamais
enregistré et puis 2012 à la californie
ont dû aux sécheresses assez sévère et
trois ans après au fait où il a moins
neigé où les températures ont été très
élevés que la tâche et que la couverture
neigeuse avec est très maigre voire même
absente dans certains endroits des
montagnes de la sierra nevada qui est
assez exceptionnel
ces montagnes de la sierra nevada sont
en quelques sortes les réserves d'eau de
la californie et de tout le sud ouest
des états unis
tout à fait donc les montagnes de la
sierra nevada et la couverture neigeuse
fourni à hauteur de 30% d'eau disponible
à la consommation pour la population en
californie cela inclut l'eau potable
l'eau utilisée pour l'irrigation mais
aussi pour générer electric power
mais comment dix ans elle est restée
l'hydroélectricité voilà ça c'est
important parce que la californie à un
climat méditerranéen qui veut dire qu'il
pleut exclusivement en hiver et il ne
peut pas au printemps et demi en l'été
donc les quantités de pluie ou plus
précisément sous forme de neige dans les
montagnes constitue malaise la redoute
qui va être utilisé plus tard dans
l'année qui s'est passé en 2015 et qu'il
n'y avait pas de couverture neigeuse au
mois d'avril en général manqué là où
entrer les mesures
ça fait déjà un record sur la période
historique avec notre étude a montré que
c'est qu'un record de bas niveau sur les
500 dernières années on voit donc des
hôtes des changements sur le climat
qu'est ce qui a changé le plus
alors ce qui est intéressant dans ce
cadre d'accueil font quelques qui a
changé d'une manière
importante que la température mais
températures ont atteint des niveaux
records spécialement aux mois d'hiver il
a fait très chaud
d'ailleurs depuis 2012 des températures
hivernales en augmenter qu'est ce qu'il
ya au fait accentuer cet extrait donc on
ressent vraiment l'effet du
réchauffement climatique sur fives
événement vraiment donc l'effet se fait
sentir hiver beaucoup oui il a un impact
sur les étaient alors les faits il est
douleur parce que quand il fait plus
chaud contre la des masses d'air qui a
eu 20 au lieu de fournir de la neige ça
va fournir de la pluie parce qu'il fait
beaucoup chouïa et le deuxième effet
c'est que ça avance et la fonte de la
neige
et c'est ton qui tombent en pluie plutôt
qu'en en neige
elle ne s'accumulent pas aussi bien
c'est tout le problème c'est que le
système pour récupérer l'eau en tout cas
en californie et adapté à la fonte des
neiges mais pas à récupérer les pluies y
a pas d'infrastructures pour récupérer
l'eau de pluie ça touche l'agriculture
la flanc la vie animale
bien sûr alors il ya eu des effets au
sentier au niveau 2 le gouverneur de la
californie a déclaré un état d'urgence
il en réduit l'utilisation de l'eau pour
l'agriculture mais aussi pour la
consommation au niveau des villes
jamais les conditions ont été aussi
sévère notre essai au fait c'est bien
sûr sur les feux de forêt lui qui a pas
eu de fonte des neiges les sols qui est
très sec donc une saison de feu de forêt
qui a acheté un dense en ce moment même
les arbres charismatique les séquoias
aux états unis commencent à ressentir
l'effet de cette sécheresse est
augmentation de température ou les
chercheurs ont noté un début de
mortalité de ces arbres et aussi de des
forêts en général niveau des montagnes
de la sierra nevada comme effet direct
d'une sécheresse prolongée qui a été
accentuée par le réchauffement
climatique la sécheresse pourrait les
tuer aussi même sens en feu de forêt
tout à fait rimer sécheresse imposa
secrète pour les arbres parce qu'ils
n'ont pas accès à l'eau et ils
deviennent beaucoup plus vulnérable aux
attaques des insectes
parce que ça change dans les
par exemple sur les activités humaines
qui est malheureux c'est que les
populations les plus vulnérables ont été
touchés par ce que fait et par ces
restrictions d'eau parce que leur seul
accès à l'eau potable s'est loupé au
niveau des puits et les niveaux des
nappes phréatiques en étaient très
basses dont ils n'ont pas accès à l'eau
potable
si cette tendance continue à la fin du
21ème siècle
on peut imaginer que des conditions de
sécheresse sévère vont devenir beaucoup
plus fréquent et que peut-être la
couverture neigeuse qui fournit l'eau
essentiellement pour l'état de la
californie par exemple ne fera qu'une
source sûre pour l'admirer qu'il faudra
s'adapter et de capturer l'eau
différemment merci soumaya belle mechri
de laboratoires de tring with such de
l'université d'arizona vous nous parliez
de tout seul au revoir
oh